(audience cheers)
(intense music)
(soft music)
♪ Small town women ain't
built to get along ♪
♪ But you burn one, boy, you burn us all ♪
♪ We'll be here drinking
'til the smoke is gone ♪
♪ You don't feel pretty ♪
♪ Light it up ♪
♪ You've been lonely ♪
♪ He's so damn lazy ♪
♪ Light it up ♪
♪ My step-kids hate me ♪
♪ And when it's gone to ashes ♪
♪ We'll be laughing, fall down drunk ♪
♪ If we fall down on our asses ♪
♪ Hell, we'll pick each other up ♪
♪ Small town women ain't
built to get along ♪
♪ But you burn one, boy, you burn us all ♪
♪ We'll be here drinking
'til the smoke is gone ♪
♪ Bonfire at Tina's ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ When memory comes around ♪
♪ Yeah, we'll go back
to talking (censored) ♪
♪ But tonight, we're all just (censored) ♪
♪ That are sick of taking it ♪
♪ Bonfire at Tina's ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Bonfire at Tina's ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, small town women
ain't built to get along ♪
♪ But you burn one, boy, you burn us all ♪
♪ We'll be here drinking
'til the smoke is gone ♪
♪ 'Til the smoke is gone ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)